.
Thank you.
THE PURPOSE OF THIS GATHERING, COMMITTEE OF CONFERENCE ON HB 1585.
EVERYONE WHO HAS BEEN DESIGNATED BY THE SPEAKER OF THE HOUSE AND THE PRESIDENT OF THE SENATE TO BE ON THIS COMMITTEE OF CONFERENCE IS HERE.
AND SO LET'S PROCEED.
REPRESENTATIVE WEBB, YOU LOOK LIKE YOU HAVE SOMETHING TO SAY.
JUST LOOKING.
OR REPRESENTATIVE MERCHANT, EITHER ONE.
Well, I um representative webby you look like you have something to say oh just looking or representative merchant either one well i i i will just say that i've had a lot of conversations with a number of people in the last couple of days and um about the house version and the senate version and they all said that they liked the senate version of the definition under Roman three on page two of the side by side because it was more restrictive than the House version.
And I kept saying, but the Senate version removed the house, the restrictions in the House version.
Roman numeral three, it says a calma is authorized to administer non-injectable medication the earlier side-by-side that i was given oh okay sorry there's more over here I thought there was one in every place.
Everybody got one?
Probably one.
We just boxed that up the wrong place.
Okay.
So let me start over again now that you've got something in front of you.
And if you turn to page two, the concern that I had with the Senate version, which people were calling me up and saying they liked very much, or at least they liked better than the House version, some of them don't like it a lot, is that it was more restrictive and simply removed the non-injectables.
The side-by-side that I was provided with up until this version did not have the word non-injectable there.
It had been adopted by the Senate.
Somehow it had not made it into one of the many versions on the website.
And so now that with the word non-injectable there, it is at least clear to me what we're talking about.
And I'm not speaking for anybody else on the House side, just myself, but I would be willing to go along with that if that gets this piece of legislation through.
We can start where we start, see how it works, start with what people are comfortable with, and then see how it evolves into practice.
So, Mr.
Chairman, unless you have any objections to that, could we tentatively agree that we would use the Senate version of that that piece of the non-objectable yeah I don't object to that okay so that means that we are in exactly the same place except that the issue is the addition of the appropriation for the nurses.
And it's a little difficult, equivocal being here on the House side because we passed it once and didn't pass it once.
So I, speaking for myself, I'd love to see that go through, but I don't know how other people on the committee of conference feel.
As a policy matter, we passed it.
Senator Perle?
I think the Senate is happy with the bill as we presented it.
We'd be happy to have you come on board.
I mean, the funding that we put into this program, it's an existing program, as you all know.
I think it's an important one.
We have a real shortage of qualified medical personnel, especially nurses and the likes that this slurper fund would cover.
And I think it's real important to leave it there.
I know Senator Gannon is very passionate about having this remain in the bill.
And at this point, I think we're here to advocate for to keep that position.
Talking about the appropriation of $300,000?
Yes.
Any other reaction?
Representative Merchant.
Thank you, Mr.
Chair.
I also support the position did pass on the policy side.
It did pass out of the Finance Committee 15 to 10.
It didn't pass the House full committee.
It went down 180.
It was 178 to 182.
Very close.
And I went back because one of the comments we had on the floor was the amount of money that a particular nurse could receive.
And to get clarification about this, if you look at the actual statute, look at the rules underneath it, there are a couple of things to bring to people's attention.
One is a nurse can only get up to $30,000 over three years, possibly $40,000 over five years.
Number two, it has to be an underserved area of the state.
Three, if they don't fulfill their obligations, not only do they have to pay back the amount of money that they were given, they have to pay it back with a penalty of 20%.
To me, those are real reasons to support the bill because we're ensuring, A, is going to go into primary care, which is what nurses are focused on.
Two, if they don't fulfill their obligation, there's a stiff penalty and it's very clear in there of what that will be.
So I don't have an issue with funding more to target it to nurses in general because I think we need nurses, particularly in underserved areas of our state, and this is a way to get there.
We'll solve the whole nursing problem.
I'm not going to be looking at it that way, but at least it starts identifying nurses and trying to attract more nurses to the undisturbed area.
looking at it that way, but at least it starts identifying nurses and trying to attract more nurses to the underserving areas of our state.
Well, Representative, you've taken my argument for why you guys should support it, so I'll concur with all the things you just said.
I mean, we're currently funding $700,000 plus into this annually, and I think additional funds are necessary in order to help alleviate the problem that we have within this industry representative nagel thanks mr chairman whatever um chairman i i just wanted to verify that all the guardrails that you just said are already in existence and that's already there because that was my only objective yeah This is this is the current existing program and that's why i began and shifted and agreed to go to he had originally uh wanted to put in a whole separate program and uh in consulting with hhs he did a lot of work with it and realized that this program was already there and was kind of really doing what he wanted to so he just looked for an increase in funding i think that if we let the house know that that's the fact i think we can get it i like with this bill a lot both of them i mean there's obviously and and you you folks and dave and probably all of us do i represent have nagel know that the appropriation is going to be a concern especially on the republican side in the house um And I'm not sure if this is going to be a poison pill for it.
That's my concern.
Yeah, that's a good point.
But we're always looking for...
And again, both of you have been in the House and on the Republican caucus.
We're always looking for good ways to spend money, you know, the right ways to spend money.
Well, we certainly find a lot just try to get it.
Would there be some appetite on the Senate side to reduce the $300,000 to a smaller number?
I think the $300 is a reasonable ask, considering what the program already does.
And I'm not sure that $100,000 or $300,000 would be any more amenable to the folks that would oppose this that the chair is discussing.
So I don't know that that would be a notable change enough to make a difference.
Senator Carson.
Thank you, Mr.
Chairman.
I think this is a worthwhile investment, and that's what we're doing.
We're making an investment not only into the health care system, but we're making an investment into people who need that health care in underserved areas.
We know we have these spots all around the state, and we really need to do everything we can to make sure that they have access to quality care.
And that means sometimes we have to put some money into it, and I think this is a worthwhile cause.
Thank you.
Representative Nagel.
I just want to let you know, I mean, I've been in medicine now for over 40 years, and I had indirect involvement with the National Health Service Corps, which is exactly what you're describing here.
And I think that was a wildly successful program.
And what was even neater about it was a lot of the people that were paying back student loans to do it ended up staying where they went.
And that's what you want.
so I mean ideally this isn't going to just a short term four-year whatever that they're going to stay there forever and be part of those communities and i think this is what we really need to do and i said that in committee if i remember right so well just to be perfectly clear this isn't a loan repayment this is kind of a contractual agreement that they have to stay and serve out a term and that's the way the nhsc work too yeah senator purpose did you have something you wanted to say i'm sorry uh no i i agree with everything that's been said i think this is a very important program i appreciate the support on the policy amendment we made which was requested by the board of nursing and by representative merchant on the floor which may have been why non-injectable didn't make it into the first version but um no i think this is great and and i tend to agree that for folks that have concern about the appropriation i don't think lowering it from 300 000 is going to alleviate that so would love to win your support for the senate version i just have one more comment because the way this was presented on the House floor was the number 50,000.
And we're not talking 50,000 here.
And I think it was a little, we need to be more persuasive in our case, if I'm not mistaken.
Anyone else?
As we all know, the vote on the floor on June 13th is going to be up or down.
There's no amending or anything like that.
And I'm just, I agree with the importance of this issue.
I'm just looking at feasibility and getting something passed.
And I'd rather have something passed than nothing.
And am I predicting what's going to happen?
Can I predict what's going to happen?
No, but I can talk about potential pitfalls, and that's what I'm talking about.
Mr.
Chair?
Yes.
Sometimes we get in places we have to make difficult decisions, and the option from our perspective is it needs to be the package as it is.
And you're willing to give up the whole thing if you can't get everything you want.
I think the bill as it is is a good piece of legislation and should gain the support of the members of the House.
Should.
Operative word.
That's why I worried.
Representative Merchant, I'm sorry.
Thank you, Mr.
Chair.
And that's kind of what I'm trying to get to is that if it goes from $300,000 to $250,000, I'm just trying to go back to our colleagues on the House side and saying there was some concession done by the Senate side recognizing we're in a fiscal non-budgetary year.
That's all I'm trying to do is how to be sure, like the Chair is talking about, we have something we can try to sell internally to the House.
That's really where I'm coming from.
I support the program 100%.
I'm just trying to figure out what's the highest probability to get something through the House.
Again, I'm not against the merits of the program.
I'm not arguing that.
I'm arguing about, you know, numbers.
Do the House conferees need to have a conference?
Because, I mean, we just, I think all the information's out here.
We just need to make a decision.
So perhaps if we could go into the office for a moment.
Anything else the Senate wants to say for us?
Only thing I will tell you is at 10.30, we have another one to be at.
So we've been a very few minutes.
I don't think that's going to take one.
Five minutes.
Excuse us.
I'm the chair.
Thanks.
Five and a half.
That's why i have five minutes we don't have a five Thank you.
Thank you.
Thank you, Mr.
Chair, I do.
I would like to...
Okay, we'll call the meeting back in order.
And Representative Merchant, did you want to make a comment?
Thank you, Mr.
Chair, I do.
I would like to propose to the Senate that we reduce it from $300,000 to $250,000.
I think it has a better opportunity to get through the House at $250,000 to, at that point in time, show to our colleagues in the House that we had some negotiations with the Senate.
That's kind of what I would propose to the senate reaction from senator pearl senator spoker perkins spoker or senator carson i guess my feeling is the same as it was before representative i respect your offer but i don't see that that's going to move the people that aren't going to vote for it if you um 250 000 300 000, 300,000, it's more about the fact you're spending money, not about the dollar value.
In my many years of being in the House, that's what I learned.
But I don't know.
You guys want to move or?
No, I think we're going to sit on 300,000 and stay with the bill as presented.
Any other comments from the House side?
Representative Weber.
If the Senate is willing to tank this whole bill over $50,000, I don't see that we have any chance other than...
Senator Perkins spoke very well.
Well, I just...
Willing to say something?
No, I mean, I can see the value, right, of being able to go to the representatives and just say the Senate conceded this small point.
I don't necessarily want to change the appropriation.
I mean, I feel like this is a good package, and there's a lot of things we've spent money on.
so i can see both sides um but i also know you guys have to be our ambassadors you know to win this vote so i'll just say you know i i might be open to it but my colleagues have to agree the question is are you or aren't you i mean i'm not sure that it's fair to say that we're tanking at over 50,000.
I mean, we could say the same the other way.
Well, the principle of the bill is we're agreeing that this is an important, important place to invest some money.
I mean, I'm not going to quibble over $50,000.
I don't I don't think that helps your argument in the House, at least personally.
I've spent an awful lot of years there myself, and there's a contingent of the House that won't vote for this because it has money.
And $250,000 or $300,000 isn't going to map.
I get that.
And the question is, are you willing to lose the other part of the bill over this part of the bill?
It sounds to me like you are.
I have no idea whether we can get this through the House at 250 or at 300, because this is the part that the House didn't agree with.
And, you know, the House position that I'm supposed to be defending on that part of the bill is take it out.
I'm for myself, I want to keep the other part of the bill is take it out.
I'm, for myself, I want to keep the other part of the bill alive.
I personally would also like to keep this part of the bill alive, but that's not the job I was sent here to do.
If you're going to walk away from the whole thing over not having the 300, then we have to roll the dice in the house.
I don't see that we've got a choice on that.
Representative Merchant, you had your hand up.
Thank you, Mr.
Chair.
I concur.
I think there are going to be some in the house that regardless if it's $10 or 300,000 are going to oppose it no matter what.
But I think if we can pull four or five, six votes, we only lost by three last time.
So we're not asking for a lot, but I'm trying to find a way to increase the probability to get to enough votes in the House to make it survive.
That's kind of what I'm trying to get to, Senator.
So Representative Nagel had made some points about now he has a better understanding of the bill.
So it isn't really about 300,000 or 250,000.
It's more about understanding of the bill.
I suspect there's many more in the House that once they have a proper explanation from you folks, that their opinion will say, you know what, the bill is worth keeping.
You haven't watched the House's voting pattern since you left have you we can hear you we're watching believe me we're watching how things work um it's just that again and i'm supporting um senator pearl's position it doesn't.
There are going to be people who are going to vote no because it's spending one dime and they don't want to spend any money.
It doesn't matter.
So, yeah, I mean, I can't see reducing it.
They're just not going to support it.
But this is good policy.
And I think you can sell this to the House members as good policy.
You have a better understanding.
And I think it should have a chance.
It should.
But I don't want to see it tank either.
But what good does it do to reduce it?
They're not going to support it anyway.
So I think your better position to go back to your House members and say, listen, we learned and we understand now that their proper guardrails are in place, the money is being spent in a good program, and that's why we can agree.
More than, we got 50 grand out of them, so vote with us.
Representative Nagel.
I'll be honest, it's like a lot of votes we have here we're not trying to sway the people the extremes we're trying to sway people in the middle i mean that's the only group we're looking at we could you know we're not changing anybody i'm aware of the time you folks now have to leave right we do very soon all right so what's the pleasure of the group?
Obviously, we know where the Senate stands.
It stays as is.
Representative Merchant?
Given the fact, I think the underlying bill to begin with is very critical to a lot of the residential facilities in order to help them out.
I'm willing to concede to the Senate $300,000 versus $250,000.
I think the roll the dice in the House and at that point in time see what happens.
I totally agree with what you're saying, Senator Pearl.
So I'm recommending to the caucus on the House side is that we keep it at $300,000 and see what we can do when it gets to the House.
Representative Navel.
Oh, I'm not.
I'm fine.
Okay.
Representative Weber, I'm assuming you are.
I am also fine.
I'm hoping very much that my friends on the other side of the aisle in the Senate will make some phone calls To people that they think might be convinced Because I think I think that would might be helpful um we all know there are people that a phone call will set off but um but i i certainly want to keep this alive by all means and senator carson you're on board senator pearl is on board senator perkins book is on board yes sir and with my reservations earlier expressed i think there's more pluses than minuses in this bill i don't want to tank the bill over and be the one that um kills this whole deal so i will support it also and i guess we'll find out next thursday and and just one further qualification Mr.
Chairman, we are all very clear because we were clear to begin with that what we are doing is exceeding to the Senate position in its entirety and we are going to be darn sure that it that the word non-injectable in is there in the version that we sign off yes yes um just to clarify Representative Weber that was a floor amendment that Representative Murchis suggested and we did pass on I I understand that night I know it happened I just was working my way through the paperwork to be sure that The next time we present it to somebody it's still in there That we all know we's what we agreed to.
Okay, okay.
All right.
We all know this has to be signed off on before 4 o'clock on Thursday.
Thank you.
We're all moving.
Have fun for the rest of your day.
Thank you.
Where are we going next?
Stand adjourned.
Are you seeing the 194?
What is it?
The one about the monuments?
Yes.
Thank you.
Yep.
No, please, please approach.
No.
Okay.
Good morning, all.
Welcome to Public Works and Highways.
We will open the Committee of Conference on House Bill 2024.
Before I do, I want to thank the Senate President for being here, Chairman Bishardi and Sandra Waters.
I'm joined by my public works, Eaton, Mills, and Cluedier.
I would just like to say before we start, collectively between the four of us sitting here, it's over 84 years of service here in the house and a great majority of that in Public Works and Highways.
I would, I'm on the understanding that the Item 7 in this, in our legislation here, Established Retirement System Benefit for Group 2 Members Who Retire Due to a Violent Act of Injury injury can be removed from here as it was taken care of elsewhere in the budget, or excuse me, elsewhere.
I would also say as a House position that we concur with the changes or amendments that were added from the Senate back to our bill.
So everything that's included in this document with taking item seven out, and I'll open it up for discussion, but I believe we as the House position are in favor of that.
Thank you.
What we are not in favor of is the Senate's position that they removed Section 10 Continental Boulevard and inserts effective dates of new subject matter added.
It is our House position, while we agree on everything else in this document, the House position is that the House was turning over Continental Boulevard from town, from state control to the town.
And that's the position, and I'm open to a discussion, that is the position of the House.
And I'll leave with one more item on that.
sitting in the room, I have other members of Public Works and Highways, which comes out to nearly 70 years of service.
I have two chairmen, a vice chairman.
It has always been the position of this committee, the Cont that the town of merrimack uh wanted wanted that highway uh entrances made uh for the turnpike system and uh legislation over the years had taken that away so i'm happy to have a conversation uh chairman.
President, if you feel that's warranted.
Thank you.
I'll be brief.
I appreciate your position on this and respectfully disagree.
The town of Merrimack has gone through an awful lot and i don't understand why they should incur this expense and maintain this road when everyone who travels it is not just from merrimack it's really is a state road i i just don't see why they should be subject to that and so i'm going to to have to disagree and stand with the people of Merrimack.
Thank you, Senator.
There are a conversation.
I'll come.
I appreciate your sentiments that it doesn't serve just the town of Merrimack, but there's not a road in the state of New Hampshire that serves just an individual town.
The fact is, I've been here 40 some regardless of the agreements, promises, and going with the history of the road from its inception to now, it should go back to where it belongs and let them continue their economic engine and take more benefit from it under their own control.
Senator Waters, please.
Thank you, Mr.
Chairman.
And, you know, I think you're going to hear very strongly we're defending the Senate position.
But just since you mentioned all the 84 years, a lot of us do have history around this, removal of the tolls, the continental boulevard issue, and so on.
And we have had either in bills or in the 10-year plan some discussion of this for quite some time.
I think that what is important as a new factor here this year is in talking with the DOT, they're saying we have learned to live with this and we understand that this is this has been the will of the legislature to have this situation and so i think that it will actually would do more harm than good at this point to merrimack uh and to the kind of principles that arose so with the removal of the tolls i said this is a lot of history here um i think also um you know i commend you mr chairman and your committee for you know once again producing great tenure plan and while i know this is an important issue to you all i would you know i I think that we risk an impasse on the bill over this.
And I don't think that's really maybe the best way to go.
But I just I think I think I think this is considered a settled by the Senate and not wanting to reopen it.
Thank you.
Thank you, Senator.
To address the issue with the Department of Transportation, we collectively are the policymakers.
Department of Transportation, I'm sure, would not come out in a position that would jeopardize any of their other operations.
But the truth of the matter is that the Turnpike system has been impacted greatly by the removal of these tolls over the years.
And as any department coming in, we have corrections here and sitting others.
They're not quick to voice opinion one way or the other.
We have lost millions of dollars.
The driver, the ridership through that area is not sustaining and coming back in numbers.
And it continues to erode our turnpike system uh if senator lou was here he'd be talking about how not being able to get his projects done in his city and others so i certainly expect that your position would be an impasse i i i want you to understand And that we may be just there for JUST THERE FOR THAT.
I MAY HAVE ONE MORE THING.
I AGREE COMPLETELY ABOUT THE TOLL SITUATION.
AND I THINK AS WE HAVE DISCUSSED, WE'RE GOING TO HAVE SOME REALLY SERIOUS CONVERSATIONS NEXT COUPLE YEARS OVER FUNDING FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF TRANSPORTATION.
WE ARE FACED WITH THE you you know inability to raise tolls in the turnpike system which i think needs to be addressed we are also faced with issues around the road toll uh in general on with the declining potential declining in vehicle miles and also the rise of evs and trying to figure out how we're going to fairly charge folks who are driving their EVs to come out of state on our roads.
I, you know, to kind of recall William Cullen, excuse me, just to recall an earlier speech, you know, I don't want to hang Merrimack on a cross of tolls.
I think we made a decision a number of years ago to take out those toll-in booths and about Continental Boulevard and reopening that right now.
I think it, in a way, I think it unfortunately makes this the issue rather than the issue of how we're going to deal with revenues for the department of transportation over the long run so i think that you know in terms of the immediate issue that may have been called by the tolls removals i think we've got to deal with the larger package which will have to you know take that into the back to here but that's that's really all i have to say about it thank Thank you, Senator.
Thank you, Mr.
Chair.
So, first of all, we all recognize that the Department of Transportation is in need of funds.
As you all know, I've been trying to get remedies for the poor families impacted by the noise barriers.
So, we know that we have a situation.
And I think it would be extremely prudent of us to work on this going forward and find solutions for the Department of Transportation to have revenues.
But my understanding prior to coming in here today is that, unless I misunderstood something, is that you were all right with the Merrimack decision that the Senate took on their position.
So I am a little surprised to hear that that is not so.
I don't think it's responsible for us to be at an impasse and put the whole entire 10-year plan at jeopardy when you did do such a good job on it.
But I do stand with the Senate position, and I do think we have to look at things on how to generate revenue and the toll situation.
But going back in time isn't going to fix the problem or holding, you know, Merrimack hostage for it.
I think what we have to do is really work collectively for the greater good and find solutions ongoing.
That's all.
Thank you.
I'm sorry, sir.
Yes, we will.
We will be in recess for five minutes.
Thank you.
Thank you all in attendance for your indulgence in allowing us the opportunity to have a couple conversations going here.
I'd like to recognize Representative Mills, and then I will go to Senate President Bradley.
Thank you, Mr.
Chair.
I just wanted to say that back in 2012, when I was a freshman here, and I don't remember the exact terms that they used to use, but we all, as new freshmen, we all had to go in and we're assigned in little groups.
And we went into different rooms and we had our first practice committee conference where we learned all the decorum, how to respond, how to address different issues.
And there was always only two episodes and they were always old bills that had failed.
One was a finance bill that I didn't sit in on, but the one that the rest of us had was the town of Merrimack, the tolls and Continental Boulevard.
And we were presented, we were presented with every piece of paper that the town had ever presented to beg the state to extend the tollway system in so that digital could go in and that exits 10, 11, 12 were put in.
Continental Boulevard was actually, I believe it was a different name at the time, but it was renamed Continental Boulevard and reinforced simply so that the DOT at the time could put in maintenance and they reinforced it for their heavy trucks.
And without a doubt, every year they did that, and there was always two outcomes.
It never passed, even in practice committees, it never passed, or there was always the option that if that ever happened, if the town ever wanted to remove the tolls, they would have to assume ownership of Continental Boulevard again.
So that's just a little history that never, ever, ever, ever went away.
Thank you.
Thank you, Representative Mills.
And I probably would just strike one word being the word beg that was offered in there.
It just it goes to the passion of this committee over the years.
Senate President Bradley.
So thank you very much, Mr.
Chair.
So I've also had a bit of history on this issue going back to when I was in the House and the town of Merrimack was trying back then in the 90s to get rid of the tolls.
having also represented Merrimack in a different part of my time, I have come to the conclusion that merrimack being the only town in the state that had to have tolls to get entrance ramps off of any of the turnpike systems was patently unfair so the question to me is how do we get to a fair solution?
And it's one of those things that probably nobody's going to be happy, but what I'm going to propose, and then I think, Mr.
Chair, we should probably take a recess afterwards, come back tomorrow, and let everybody have a chance to digest it.
But what I'm going to propose is that we continue state maintenance of of um continental boulevard for five years so it would be 2029 i believe that would um put the town of merrimack past the next paving upgrade which i think is probably the next two or three years from what the commissioner has said.
It would allow both sides to have an opportunity to readdress it in five years.
But for the town of Merrimack, who probably thinks I'm selling them down the drain, I really am not.
Because here's why.
This issue is going to come back every 10-year highway plan.
We could hold tight.
We could threaten to walk.
We could play chicken.
Somebody wins.
Somebody loses.
Maybe we don't have a 10-year plan.
Maybe we do.
If we don't have a 10-year plan, everybody loses.
So I think, you know, in my conversations with, you know, Representative McConkie, we've both agreed that a 10-year plan, killing it over Continental Boulevard is just a non-starter, okay?
That's just a reality, or it should be a reality.
So, in my mind, coming up with something that gives the town of Merrimack five years of breathing room and a paving is something that you don't have right now.
Because this issue, even if the Senate position establishes itself over the next, you know, two days, and everybody agrees, the House backs down, Continentallevard stays in reality is in it it ain't going away it's coming back in 2026 next 10-year plan same thing it'll be fought representative mcconkey hopefully he'll be a senator life may look a little different but maybe it won't look different but there'll be other people that are trying to do the same thing.
So my proposal will give you five years of, you know, more certainty and a paving.
So I hope that we can take a recess for 24 hours, let everybody cogitate on it from Merrimack to the commissioner's office, to the House, and to colleagues in the senate so that's what i would propose i'm happy to prepare the amendment and uh we come back and i i would also say mr chair um and madam chair um having never sat on 10-year plan but having worked on capital budgets for a while uh you guys did a great great job really fantastic job and um really glad that that bridge in charlestown is going to be delayed a couple of years to solve that problem uh representative mcconkey and i totally agree on the situation in the 45 mile an hour speed limit you Albany, the town that we both represent.
That's a really helpful step.
Thank you for seeing it our way on the 40 year or $40 million bonding for the prison.
A lot of good work has been done.
So by proposing what I'm proposing, I'm trying to be fair to everybody.
So thank you.
Mr.
Chair.
Thanks, Senator.
Okay, I want to commend Senator Bradley for trying to cement in an effort to reach compromise, which is aIDE OVER HERE, AS WE'VE HEARD FROM THE OTHER TWO SENATORS.
SO MY UNDERSTANDING IS THAT THE AMENDMENT TO HOUSE BILL 2024 WOULD REMOVE THE RETIREMENT SYSTEM BENEFIT FOR GROUP TWO, WHICH WE AGREE WITH.
And I would suggest, and I'm open for debate, why don't we prepare an amendment that does exactly what we're speaking of, have it prepared, and perhaps take a break today and prepare it, have it done, and have it prepared to be signed off this week, as opposed to having another meeting.
I know how busy you folks are.
Would you agree to that, Senator?
I would.
I just think in fairness to the town of Merrimack that they probably should have a little bit of chance to talk among themselves longer than five minutes.
So I do want to recess to later this hour, not recess, take a break for an hour.
I probably can't come back until four o'clock because how about 4 p.m.
for the I know that you're not available, but we have a majority.
I can come back.
I'm in a problem.
If it stays the same, you don't have to be here to vote.
You don't have to be here to vote, but I think we should come back.
I think it's important to Merrimack that they get the reps in merrimack a little time to discuss themselves well i have two members i have uh i would like to have the senate here the uh what what what does your uh thursday look like you can do four okay or or tomorrow yeah yeah i'm mr chairman i can't be here tomorrow until it was very late it'd have to be probably four or later because of my juice so i'll i'll ask i'll ask our staff to prepare that amendment today anytime tomorrow i'll ask our staff to prepare an amendment i think we ought to see the actual language okay.
I'm happy with that.
So four o'clock tomorrow?
Today.
Today?
But I can do tomorrow too.
I have more flexibility tomorrow.
I'm sorry.
Okay.
Why don't, why don't we go?
Yeah, I can stay okay well david well we won't be a boat we're going to be looking i can't i can't appoint anybody for your your missing my missing members at this point in time so they can sign off with representative smith's okay after so as as long as we all understand i'm more than happy to come back for four o'clock we'll give them some time to have a conversation we'll draft the amendment i think it probably should end up coming through the house though but if you want to write the language we're more than happy to do that.
We can put it in your name.
Okay, sounds good.
I'll let Grant do it, though.
All right, and then we'll come back for 4 o'clock.
Thank you.
But it would appear at this point in time we're in agreement, but we want to see the amendment.
All right.
Thank you.
Thank you CLOSE THE COMMITTEE CONFERENCE ON HOUSE BILL 2024, AND WE WILL OPEN OUR NEXT 12.
12.02 in 2 minutes.
I just have to grab my paperwork.
Thank you.
I once again apologize for a little bit of a delay, having come out of our committee of conference just prior to this I am some say on the legislative side when you've been at this a while that this is almost the Super Bowl when we get down to the end but our goal always here is to is to get to a yes is where we're looking to be and compromise where we go.
So I would just like to recognize Representative Walnut sitting here, Vice Chairman Cloutier and myself, and Senator Richardi, if you could introduce your senators.
Thank you, Representative McConkie and Chair.
This is senator waters and senator gendron thank you um the bill uh the bill before us house bill 1202 was um came out of the special committee on housing uh which was brought forward by the speaker's office he and so many on both sides of this aisle recognized that we have a a real issue with working families with residents in general not being able to find affordable housing We had conversations for well over a year with developers and activist groups trying to find housing for people.
And we settled after a year on what sort of projects could we bring forward that would aid in speeding up the delivery of people wanting to build or developers in the process.
One of the sticking points that we had come to with some of the developers, especially in the southern part of the state, was how long it could take to get to yes on providing a driveway permit.
We had a lot of conversations with the department.
This is what we're proposing here is an evolution of that.
We had looked for a 30-day window, and this has been moved to 60 days.
I'm proud of that compromise.
We worked hard to get there.
The Senate, in their inevitable wisdom, has agreed with our position on that, but then has added on top of that the issue of definition of disability special needs under child care would um i would welcome one of the senators to address that issue and the importance of that to us please oh thank you mr chair um i'm going to give an overview first if that's okay so people listening can understand but uh yes i work uh as often as possible with stakeholders in addressing the different issues for child care and children at risk of developmental disability.
And while our existing child care framework provides necessary support for children with diagnosed disabilities, it unfortunately leaves behind those at the cusp of developmental challenges, those not yet diagnosed but showing clear signs of being at risk.
And that early intervention can make such a difference on the outcome of that child as they grow into becoming an adult.
These are children who show clear delays in their motor function, speech, cognitive play, and social-emotional development.
Children who often later receive formal diagnosis, such as maybe autism or attention deficit disorder and other learning impairments.
The evidence is clear.
The earlier way I identify that we intervene and support children who are at risk for development delay, the greater the likelihood that the child is later able to catch up academically with their peers.
So to address this issue, I introduced Senate Bill 596, which would just expand the definition of disability within our child care scholarship program.
Advocates working with the Department of Health and Human Services proposed an amendment to 596, which did not change the intent, but more efficiently outlined the process necessary to strengthen the deferential payments.
So the amended version would enable Department of Health and Human Services to enter rulemaking to define the class of children and ensure that definition includes not only children that are diagnosed a delay, but those at a higher risk.
So it would enable DHHS to work with experts and advocates to identify the proper screening tools and the verification needed to ensure eligible children can get the support that they need.
Child care differential payments as it currently exists is grossly underutilized by our providers, in part because so few children can demonstrate a diagnosable disability when they're under the ages of three or four years old.
The policy change is not about supporting children, but also about bolstering our child care providers and enabling access to differential payments for at-risk children.
We can then provide centers with the necessary resources to maintain appropriate ratios and offer high quality care, thereby expanding access to child care for all families across our state.
With access to differential payments, centers will be able to bring in some additional staff capacity and classroom support to assist in providing these children with the hands-on learning support they need to be successful.
In conclusion, this bill represents a strategic, evidence-informed approach to enhancing our child care system.
It ensures that children, particularly those at risk of developmental delays, receive the support they need during their most informative.
I want to thank all of you for being here and willing to listen and work on this, and I really appreciate it.
Thank you very much.
Thank you, Sandra.
When I heard that this was added on to our bill, I took a special interest in it, and I tried to find what the financial burden would be to the state for this to move forward.
And I was told, and I have Representative Walner here from finance, that if this moves forward in its present form, that this is a gap that would provide funding until the next budget would come forward.
And so my next question is, is this a million dollars?
Is this a three-quarter million?
Is this a half a million?
And when you start coming south of there, it starts catching my attention and getting me more in agreement.
Representative Waldner, my understanding is that this is less than $400,000 at the current estimate and possibly in the $350,000 range.
Am I correct in my assumption?
I believe that you probably will find that in the end, this will probably even be less than the $300,000.
This program right now, in the last fiscal year, it spent $96,000, a very small amount served about a hundred children.
And I can't imagine that this would do would double that.
Maybe it might pick up a few few more children, but not not double the program.
So I think that I think we're within safe range.
Thank you.
I mean, yes, please, Senator Waters, please.
And understanding this and the possibility of federal grants, I would point to the last part of the bill where it does say discretionary funds under ARPA and then federal funds, but any remainder not to exceed $1 shall be from general funds.
So I think that that, you know, as much, I mean, it's hard to anticipate what the cost would be, but I think the language of the bill is structured to ensure that we have a lot of control over what and whether or how much at this, and there's no disagreement with the survival program.
And it's done kind of a funny way because way because you know that last day we had to put stuff on this and that you know all about it but and I suppose daycare centers want to have driveways too okay but um I I I think that um this is a nice way of getting this the probe with the principles there the bridge the you know light touch on funding, and then gets us into the next budget where I cannot imagine a budget not wanting to take care of this program in the future.
So that's I just want to point out in the bill.
Thank you, Sandra.
I welcome your words that you just provided.
Is there anyone else who wants to speak to it before we pull this?
John, are you okay?
John D.
I'm in favor, I don't know, with all due respect, to adding this to the 1202.
It's a worthwhile program, getting a lot of emails from throughout the state.
That's what I believe.
John D.
Thank you.
Thank you, Representative Kludier.
I also have a small business owner, excavation convenience store and other activities, and so many younger people than me raising families, the child care, and anything we can do to bring that forward and make this better will just increase our workforce.
And whatever we can do to keep families living in our state is, I believe, is our charge that to me is one of the most important things.
So unless I hear different, we would concur.
The House will concur with this legislation as written.
Thank you.
We concur.
Good.
Thank you.
I'll sue your office in a minute.
Yes.
Thank you all for attending, and that will take care of our business on this.
Sign-off must be done on Thursday.
4 p.m., I believe.
4 p.m., not 4.01, when Mark likes to be a couple minutes late.
Thank you all.
Well, thanks for all you helping.
Thank you.
I'd like to return back to Committee of Conference from our morning session, House Bill 2024.
I want to thank Senate President Bradley for the work you've done to bring this forward and the amendment, Chairman Rashardi, and Senator Waters.
So if I...
It looks to me the spirit of what we talked about this morning, Section 6 reclassifies Continental Boulevard, Town of Merrimack, as a Class 5 highway beginning July 1 of 2029 is in, which was the house position.
It adds everything we talked about this morning, a speed limit 45 miles an hour, capital appropriation for the replacement of the New Hampshire State Prison, and all the other projects that we had agreed to remain.
Did Senator Birdsell's section get removed?
Yeah, it's not shown in here, so it's removed.
You're okay?
Senators, the House position is that we would concur with, with this as amended.
Okay.
Thank you so much for your time.
Really appreciate it.
I could add, I know that there's maybe a little bit of consternation from the Merrimack delegation, but honestly, I think you are so much better off with this amendment and five years of certainty than fighting it every two years.
So I hope that the good folks at Merrimack will realize what we've done is actually in their benefit.
So, at any rate, I hope so.
Thank you.
We'll call the committee a conference to a close.
Thank you all.